We have an interesting
day here in Los Angeles.
It's cold and raining,
and that never happens.
I know.
And you were out in the courtyard,
there's a little courtyard
here at the theater,
and you had to come in, you were so cold.
I got chilly.
Yeah.
I got chilly, and I don't get chilly.
So yeah, no, it's fun.
I love it when it's like this.
I love it like this, and I also love
that everybody in Los Angeles overreacts.
If the temperature hits 62,
people act as if there's a
meteor headed towards earth
and we're all going to die within seconds.
They scream, they run, they
crash their cars into walls.
They put on their big down
parkas, 'cause it's 58.
Yeah, everyone here looks
like a Nordic explorer.
Anywho, tough guys like
me that grew up in Boston,
we don't worry about this weather.
And tough guys do this all the time.
This is just what a tough guy does.